in the lobby of the headquarters for
Ramsay Solutions Robert and Lindy are
with us hey guys how are you good Dave
pretty good good to have you guys now
where do you live so we live in uh
Queensland Australia so just out west of
Brisbane it's where I'm stationed
currently so you just uh dropped by uh
Nashville to see us huh yeah just a
random stop by yeah just uh I think this
could be the furtherest travel to do an
inless Lobby debt free scream I think
you get the award that was the goal yeah
red hog go it's like 20 something hours
25 hours probably to get here uh 12 and
a half Brisbane yeah so 13 hours to LA
from Brisbane and then we had a nice
long round trip through Seattle via
Seattle to hours oh okay yeah okay wow
long trip yeah I guess so so how how
long have you been in the states uh what
4 days
okay so you had time to adjust a little
bit so the jet leg's not still kicking
your butt okay we left the kids with
family in California Lindy's parents
live there okay that's fine holidaying
with the grandparents anyon so uh H I'm
pretty sure my radio shows don't show up
over there maybe the podcast is that it
does yeah so we got the podcast okay so
I listen to that most days okay I'll get
the Bluetooth into the stereo yeah just
the iTunes then huh okay yeah we have
our iTune account set in America cuz I
don't think we can get it from the AUST
iTunes store right that's exactly right
okay very cool you guys well I'm and and
that's how you connected up with us yeah
I knew about you before I moved okay um
I kind of did it half-heartedly until I
did the move oh and so you're from
California I'm from tari California okay
very cool so how much debt have you paid
off it was 141,000 okay is that American
or Australian uh mix of both okay
the love around okay how long did it
take uh 41 months all right and your
range of income during that time uh it
fluctuated a fair bit so we had about
140 that we started off at and uh Lindy
had a sudden job loss M um so that
quickly took us back down to 75 and we
got we're a bit lost we didn't know
really what we were going to do so we
both started up little businesses so
even though I was serving we um were
able to boost our income back up with me
doing some and Lindy picking up a little
side business and kicking that off and
that got us back up to around 100 good
deal good deal I love it love it so uh
what kind of debt was the 141,000 we had
everything yeah a lot so there was a
there was a house that Lindy hadent in
Arizona mhm uh and then we just had
Consumer Debt car loans credit cards my
University loan mhm yeah so the regular
stuff really yeah did you sell the house
Arizona I did and what did it bring I
was just around 95 okay all up so that
helped a bunch that was about 100 of the
141 right gotcha okay so what happened
41 months ago that put you on this
journey to get out of debt that's when I
moved to Australia mhm yeah I met blendy
while I was stationed over here and
decided to drag her back home with me
and then uh yeah we uh went from there
that just shook up both our worlds I
just I didn't want to be in debt and not
have the ability to get on a plane if I
needed to whether it was a family
emergency or MH I needed RNR or
something so what made you guys decide
to work this system the podcast how' you
find our podcast how did you I knew
about you before because you knew before
okay Wendy bought it with her and then
um my bad influence she's she had the
Financial Peace University and uh she
said oh look I really like this plan and
well she's a pretty smart woman so I
thought I'll listen to her and I I just
played the um the CDs in my car driving
to and from work I got about a 40 to 45
minute commute out to the base so yeah
we just i' just listened to that got got
through all the lessons there and went
yeah let's go okay so you said stationed
in base so you're Australian military
yeah Royal Australian Air Force okay wow
well thank you for your service to that
country that's awesome thank you very
cool how does it feel now to have any
debt it's surreal yeah we it it kind of
comes in waves you sort of you real
there you get those little bits of
Freedom like like this trip like we were
able paid for it in cash had savings
like we finished paying off our debt a
few months ago and just the money we had
once we weren't paying money to anyone
else we were just able to go oh geez we
can we can just pay cash for this thing
yeah yeah originally we just planned for
him and I to come out here and then I
was saving we're putting it away and I
was like well we're going to clear our
debt I mean we're going to clear our
goal pretty quick so we have all three
kids out here ah okay airfare is not
cheap yeah and they got to see Mom and
Dad huh yeah Grandpa Grandma yeah good
very cool neat very neat so what do you
tell people when they ask how you paid
off 141,000 41 months well we tell them
about you that's for sure just follow
the plan like it's it's just practical
it's it's basic but it works it's just
that good old kiss br principle it's
just simple keep it simple just keep
chugging along no matter how hard it
gets and those things that you want
you've just got to go I I'll wait and
I'll get it yeah we get them just that
looking into the future rather than just
next week makes such a difference so how
long have you been in the military I've
served 12 years now okay so the
discipline that's in the military how
much did that assist you in having
discipline in this area uh probably
probably a fair bit um yeah Lindy
yeah this one once it's game on it's
game on it is it's game on okay got
that's cool yeah so you kind of created
a monster there Lindy
yeah good a good monster though it's
very good congratulations you two thank
you very well done and we're honored to
have you be our uh I know you're our
first Australian in the studio now we've
had call-ins but this is the first the
first one in the studio and by far the
longest travel uh to date Kelly Daniels
keeps up with the stuff and she was
telling me at the break she said this is
they get the award for the longest
travel so very cool all the way from
Queensland Australia so very fun and of
course we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's
retire inspired book signed by him for
you and that'll take you to the the
retire inspired number one National
bestseller take you to the next chapter
in your story from debt free to wealthy
and uh be able to live and give like no
one else which is the goal here so very
good congratulations you two very proud
of you thanks Dave and thanks for taking
the trouble to come all the way here man
that's very cool all right it's Robert
and Lindy Queensland Australia
$141,000 paid off in 41 months making
140 down to 75 then back up to 100 count
it down let's hear a debt-free
Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb
free love it love it love
it
awesome it's very fun
very fun hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
Subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]